Well, let's see.
3 miles,
that's the distance we're working with.
And I'm going to be
relating miles to feet, so
it looks like I'm going to
use this statement somehow.
And I know I want to
multiply by something,
but what's my conversion
factor going to be?
Is it going to be 1 mile
divided by 5282 feet?
No, it can't be,
because miles doesn't cancel out.
Here we have miles up top and
feet down below.
What we really want is to cancel
out this unit of miles so
that we're left just with feet.
So this, this is wrong.
Instead I'm going to multiply
by 5280 feet divided by 1 mile.
And I'm allowed to do that.
It doesn't matter if feet or
miles goes on top because either
way I'm multiplying by 1.
I just have to select
the correct conversion factor so
that miles will cancel out.
I'm left with 3 x 5280.
My units are feet.
And if I plug this into my calculator or
do some multiplication,
I find a distance of 15,840 feet.